[Musik]
live aus köln der presseclub mit jörg
schönenborn
herzlich willkommen an diesem
sonntagmittag schön dass sie dabei sind
erinnern sie sich noch an den start der
ampel koalition im herbst an das
selbstbewusstes elfi von fdp und grünen
spitzen mit der botschaft wir sind die
fortschritts koalition das was merkel
und scholz da vor allem in sachen
klimaschutz gemacht hatten wurde als
stillstand empfunden und sollte sich
ändern heute ein halbes jahr später ist
dieser fortschrittsmotor in sachen klima
ins stottern gekommen das hat mit dem
krieg zu tun wir verfahren wieder viel
mehr kohle damit das gas für den winter
gespeichert wird das hat aber auch damit
zu tun dass die koalition sich nicht
einig ist wie sie ihre versprechen
umsetzte vergangenen mittwoch war uns
eigentlich ein großes klimaschutz
sofortprogramm versprochen worden was
wir bekamen waren einzelne ideen zwei
minister unabgestimmt und wie sehr die
lösungen auf diesem feld not tut das
sehen wir im moment in jeder ausgabe der
tagesschau das sind bilder von gestern
abend aus portugal rund um das
mittelmeer brennt der wald lichterloh
dauer temperaturen teilweise über 40
grad führen zu starker hitze in italien
leidet vor allem der norden unter
größter trockenheit wir haben das glück
dass die hitze nicht in voller wucht zu
uns kommt wahrscheinlich ist es nur ein
tag mit temperaturen die dann über 35
grad sind aber keine frage das thema ist
da gaskrise koalitionsstreit leere
kassen scheitert die klimapolitik der
ampel und ich freue mich auf diese gäste
michael fabricius ist bei uns er leitet
bei der tagesschau in einem nicht mehr
der tagesschau bei der tageszeitung welt
die immobilien redaktion ich freue mich
auf kathrin dick sie ist teamleiterin
energie und klima beim handelsblatt
petra pinzler ist wieder bei uns
korrespondentin derzeit in berlin und
sven plöger meteorologe und bekannt aus
dem ard wetterstudio
der kläger ich habe es gerade gesagt das
verbrennen von mehr kohle in unseren
kraftwerken hat begonnen damit wir im
winter noch ein bisschen gas wirklich
haben für warmes wasser und warme
wohnungen wie tief müssen sie schlucken
wenn sie das mit blick auf die
klimaanlage sehen ist das richtig so
sehr tief ich bin meteorologe für mich
ist im ersten moment natürlich immer das
entscheidend was in der atmosphäre
geschieht ich beobachte dass ich sehe
jetzt eine erwärmung global von 1,2 grad
wir sind kurz vor 1,5 wir spüren das
extremwetter alle überall sie haben es
gerade gezeigt und gesagt trotzdem gilt
natürlich folgendes wir haben durch
jahrelanges verschlafen das muss man so
offen sagen uns in eine lage
hineinmanövriert die uns jetzt
krieg putin
letztendlich dazu zwingt im letzten
moment die dinge zu tun die irgendwie
noch helfen ich vergleiche das ich bin
selber bin ich segelflieger und so ein
segelflieger der macht einen landeanflug
und dann setzte auf und wenn der
landeanflug ganz schlecht gelaufen ist
dann macht man um nachher keine
bruchlandung zu machen als pilot noch
alles um irgendwie zu landen und ich
habe das gefühl wir haben einen sehr
schlechten landeanflug seit 2007
hingelegt man hat putin damals auf der
sicherheitskonferenz ist es in münchen
sehr genau seine weltsicht
anhören können man hat dann verfolgt was
getan wurde wir haben politisch weltweit
grundsätzlich nicht reagiert konsequent
nicht ob das georgien auf das später die
krim und so war und jetzt kriegen wir
das ganze irgendwo ein stückweit
heimgezahlt wir haben dinge und dann
wenn mein satz auch zu ende wir haben
dinge wie nord trieben zwei über viele
viele jahre geplant und gleichzeitig
großartig gesagt wir wollen raus aus der
fossilen energie so eine lange brücke
und sprach von brückentechnologie habe
ich in meinem leben gedanklich noch nie
erlebt ich habe es nie verstanden
und jetzt kriegen wir das auf den tisch
was zu erwarten gewesen ich glaube das
ist tragen frack künstler wie weit wirft
uns das zurück und klimaschutz
im moment massiv also die frage dieser
sendung ist ja unter anderem ob wir
gescheitert sind mit der klimapolitik
und die ampel gescheitert ist das muss
man leider im moment mit einem klaren ja
beantworten jetzt kann man lange darüber
reden dass das nicht nur ihre schuld ist
sondern tatsächlich da weil ich so ein
blöder völlig zustimmen die schuld der
regierungen der merkel regierungen davor
die hat viel verschlafen das kann diese
regierung nicht alles aufholen sie hat
zusätzlich eben im moment noch das
problem dass ich tatsächlich mehr kohle
verfeuern muss weil uns das russische
gas ausgeht aber es ist ja nicht nur so
dass ihr in den bereichen wo man das
vielleicht noch entschuldigen könnte
also bei der energieversorgung anfängt
im moment zu zu stottern sondern sie tut
es eben auch bei den gebäuden und beim
verkehr wir werden darüber bestimmt
gleich noch reden also in bereichen wo
man im klimaschutz lange weiß dass da
was passieren muss und auch diese ampel
regierung kriegt das bisher nicht hinter
gegenzusteuern frau betritt fortschritte
stillstand sehen sie im moment in der
klimapolitik ja ich muss da von der
kollegin total zustimmen viel zu viel
stillstand was wir die woche gesehen
haben was ja eigentlich ein großes
gesamtprogramm sein sollte waren jetzt
nur so ein paar häppchen paar brocken
keine details sehr ungenau vor allem aus
dem verkehrsministerium und da ist es
auch viel passiert das darf man finde
ich nicht unerwähnt lassen dass unser
paket von robert habeck ist jetzt auch
beschlossene sache da steht schon
einiges drin also ich finde das passiert
mehr als in den letzten jahren davor
aber es muss deutlich schneller gehen
das ist ja auch nicht so schwer dass da
mir das hier ja das stellte zudem
autorisiert mehr herr fabricius
also im moment passiert vor allem etwas
was herr bürger dazu bringen wird im
nächsten jahr noch mal mehr zu schlucken
wahrscheinlich war der wenn die
kohlekraftwerke noch mal mehr
hochgefahren werden müssen weil wir
gleichzeitig auch noch aus der atomkraft
aussteigen also nicht nur das wir und
deswegen finde ich es gut dass sie so
früh eingesetzt haben zeitlich 2007 man
kann sogar noch weiter zurückgehen die
subventionierung der solarindustrie hat
auch zu einem abwandern
der paneele herstellung nach china
geführt all das hat schon stattgefunden
in früheren jahren dem wir uns auf das
russische gas verlassen als ausgleich
für leistungsschwache phasen bei sonne
und wind strom ja jetzt ist das gas weg
jetzt wird aber auch noch der atomstrom
weg sein das heißt im nächsten jahr
bleibt uns im wesentlichen
kohle und braunkohle um diese grundlast
herzustellen den wir im winter verein
brauchen jetzt muss man sagen
tatsächlich also ist passiert was nicht
in allen ministerien fehler vielleicht
aber wenn man die programme ankommt den
letzte woche vorgestellt worden sind ich
fand das was aus dem bauministerium
gekommen ist gar nicht so schlecht da
gibt's ein paar konkrete vorstellungen
die auch etwas weiter gehen als das was
wir früher hatten vielleicht auch
mangels bauministerium jetzt geht es
ganz konkret um
kommunale wärmenetze jahr also richtig
ein bisschen auch vom einzelne haus weg
wir haben immer darauf geguckt dass wir
jedes einzelne haus zu der perfekten
effizienz maschine machen dass da jetzt
ein bisschen anders also das finde ich
vom gedanken ansatz her schon mal
richtig ein bisschen schwieriger wird
wahrscheinlich da gehen wir vielleicht
im detail darauf ein dass ein heizungs
vorschriften demnächst kommt das sieht
erstmal super aus wird uns aber vor neue
probleme stellen ich wollte erst mal
praktisch auf einem sofortprogramm
kommen dass wir glaube ich alle oder
zumindest viele von uns im alltag gerade
gestartet haben die preise die note wie
man am ende die gas und stromrechnung
bezahlt hat ja erkennbar viel verhalten
geändert man spricht im alltag darüber
wie tief man das wasser runter dreht und
ob man kürzer duscht gibt sogar
ministerielle tipps dafür wenn ich mit
dem auto unterwegs bin merklich spürbar
weniger raser bahnen und busse sind voll
dank neun euro ticket ist so aus der gas
not eine klima tugend geworden ist das
ein tiefgreifender wandel den wir gerade
erleben das muss man natürlich hoffen
und das ist traurig dass es im moment so
gesehen werden muss und kann aber ich
glaube dass schon also ich habe selten
auch im persönlichen und beruflichen
umfeld so viel über dieses thema
gesprochen selten habe ich so viele
menschen danach gefragt wie kann man
denn jetzt in kiel sparen was soll ich
jetzt machen und ich glaube das ist
natürlich wie man sagt ja aus der not
eine tugend machen das muss jetzt
passieren das kann ja die einzige
richtige lösung sein und von da muss man
sagen das muss man jetzt auch nutzen
und das passiert finde ich noch viel zu
wenig gerade und thema energiesparen auf
politischer ebene bis auf die dusch
tipps und robert habeck aber da ist
natürlich noch viel mehr möglich wenn
ich glaube es deutlich zu wenig passiert
im moment wird das so ein bisschen
outgesourced zu haben der darf und soll
darüber reden aber die anderen teil der
bundesregierung ducken sich noch weg
vorbei witz hat als ist um die
temperatur unter also darum gehen ob man
vielleicht zwei prozent weniger hohe
raumtemperatur verlange grad
da muss der meteorologe
sie hat darauf reagiert indem sie gesagt
hat man will ja nicht frieren also bei
18 19 grad friert man noch nicht also
ich glaube dieses gefühl in der
bundesregierung dass es unsere krise und
es reicht nicht den heiligen durch tipp
geben zu lassen sondern wir müssen alle
versuchen die leute dazu zu bringen zu
sagen wir alle können was machen das ist
so eine art mitmacht krise und und
ungesehen absolut dem stimme ich zu aber
wir müssen auch wirklich mal erkennen
dass wir in der vergangenheit wir neigen
dazu uns immer die welt schön zu reden
dann ist das billige gas gut dann sind
wir einfach auf dem kurs und machen ganz
andere dinge als wir sagen also werden
wir neigen dazu sagen und auch den
klimaschutz immer wieder zu
transportieren als wichtiges politisches
thema aber nachher b zu machen oder
allenfalls a halbe und da langen wir
jetzt einfach und jetzt haben wir genau
die herausforderung müssen uns getrauen
bestimmte diskussion zu stellen und was
mir zum beispiel sehr schwer fällt zu
begreifen ist ich war letzte woche es
ist jetzt ja die flutkatastrophe im
aartal hat sich gewehrt ich bin dort
gestanden ich habe mal wieder dort die
häuser gesehen ich habe mit den leuten
gesprochen ich habe wieder das leid
gesehen und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
wir sind doch auch diesen menschen dort
vor ort und noch tragischer denen die
verstorben sind ein stück weit schuldig
auch aktiv wirklich mal zu reagieren was
ich absolut nicht verstehe ist warum
schaffen wir es in deutschland nicht das
zu tun was in europa alles tun was in
holland sogar auf 100 kilometer pro
stunde begrenzt ist eine
geschwindigkeits ein tempolimit ich weiß
selber achtung ich weiß selber dass da
ganz viel jetzt kommen kann ich weiß
selber dass jetzt sicherlich auch mails
geschrieben werden ich weiß sicher das
verbot immer was schwieriges ist aber
man kann ja mal die zahlen angucken
erster bürger jahre sind spannendes
beispiel ich will ich will ich will es
einmal einordnen in ihren rahmen dann
sind sie ja daran lernen also was ja
auch glaube ich bei den parteien in der
bundesregierung unterschiedlich gesehen
wird man kann ja mit der grundhaltung
rangehen wir sind mündige menschen und
aus vernunft und eigenem entschluss tun
wir etwas was der gesellschaft was dem
planeten dient oder man kann rangehen
und kann sagen wir brauchen klare regeln
an die sich jeder und jeder halten muss
das ist ja in teilen auch der konflikt
beim tempolimit innerhalb der
bundesregierung das muss diskutiert
werden absolut wenn man kochen dann
regeln oder ich glaube der band sprach
er dann breiter ich glaube er war regeln
also
haben wir natürlich geregelt aber wir
sehen ja dass wir im mittel also es gibt
ja immer noch die berechnung also
erstens
vorwiegend sind die menschen in dieser
gesellschaft der meinung dass wir das
schaffen müssten und dass wir eine
solche begrenzung haben das wollen die
meisten menschen das finde ich
interessant punkt zwei es gibt sehr
unterschiedliche zahlen was man durch so
eine tempobegrenzung die freiwilligkeit
bringt ein bisschen was geschrieben soll
ich dir mal kurz vor jahren nur gerade
diese vision sind zwei also diese zwei
bis neun millionen tonnen die da stets
diskutiert werden ist eine sehr große
bandbreite weil man natürlich mit ex
wegen rechnen kann wenn wir jetzt aber
hören dass das verkehrsministerium
darüber diskutiert dass wir drei
millionen tonnen einsparen müssen und
herr lindner sagt das ist marginal was
wir erzielen dann sehe ich bei zwei bis
neun millionen tonnen nicht magath
sondern sie etwas bedeutet das heißt da
sehen chancen ich finde es und das
möchte ich als letzten satz st ich finde
es vor allen dingen wichtig als signal
als signal gegenüber menschen die unter
den klimaänderungen die wir erleben
leiden als signal zu vermitteln wir als
gesellschaft sind bereit irgendetwas
wirklich zu beginnen und uns nicht immer
wieder auf diese freiheit und
selbstverantwortung oder regeln ich
finde es so eine sowohl der ökonomische
die idee von freiheit wenn man sagt das
schränkt die freiheit massiv ein wären
nicht nur noch tempo 100 fahren darf
meine freiheit ein wenn ich bei einer
roten ampel halten muss oder es gibt ja
in noch wirtschaftlichen zu den
gesellschaftlich zusammenlegen gibt sich
regeln und ich finde man muss sich
überlegen wie sind die prioritäten des
umweltbundesamt hat es mal ausgerechnet
also nur 23 zahlen ohne sie zu
erschlagen tempo 100 würde 3,8 prozent
das öl darf so dass das benzin und sprit
bedarf bringen sind tempo 80 auf
landstraßen 0,8 wenn man so wie in den
niederlanden alle fahrten unter 20
kilometer und versucht mit dem fahrrad
zu fahren nochmal 2,9 wenn wir versuchen
alle jede zweite freizeit gemacht aber
das war eine zweite sind insgesamt
unterlassen so lassen uns zahlen sparsam
sein okay was ich damit sagen will es
dass dieses viele kleinvieh auch mist
und bei all dem was dann tatsächlich
passiert das ist das neu im grunde ja
noch eine ganz kurze sache zum teil
sagen herr bürger also werden nicht
durch ein tempolimit solche
hochwasserkatastrophen bin absolut nicht
sagen dass alles wieder so ein bisschen
direkt verknüpft und deshalb gefährlich
weil sonst sieht man die falsche
schlussfolgerung lautet wir müssen mehr
co2 emissionen einsparen und dann kommt
weniger hochwasser kann das wird sowieso
alle erst müssen wir natürlich das wird
so sein das kann ich hier brauche ich
jetzt ein hochwasserschutz wir müssen
rückhaltebecken bauen wir brauchen
vernünftige denke das ist auch nicht
überall richtig gewesen an der elbe
wurde das gemacht es ist nicht überall
der fall das müssen wir überprüfen
in allen modellen land muss nicht so
sein dass einfach über die ufer treten
dann brauchen wir wirkungsvolle und
funktionierende meldekette nja im
katastrophenschutz und in der behörde
gerne einen cut machen was dich zudem
war es ja genau aber wir sind ja bei der
frage tempolimit evesen verbote also da
ob wir gerade alle vernünftig werden
unser verhalten
langfristig ändern weil uns die
gaspreise mehr weh tun als die bilder
von abstürzenden deutschland also da
sehe ich schon relativ klare wirkung
über das ganz schlichte preissignal am
markt wenn die heizkosten so der
absteigen oder auch die spritkosten die
leute fahren weniger auto es gab jetzt
bereits eine 14 prozent gas ersparnis in
den privaten haushalten in den monaten
seit dem krieg und wenn es jetzt im
winter nochmal teurer werden sollte das
gas die leute sind sehr bei der zur lage
auf die rechnung zu kommen und zu
überlegen ich rede gesagt drei signale
sind ungerecht während ordnungsrecht
eigentlich gerechter ist weil wir sagen
die leute dürfen nicht schneller als 100
fahren dann trifft das den menschen mit
dem porsche genauso wie den mit dem mit
dem ortsmitte mit dem kleinen alten auto
während der mann diese weise allianz ist
verwischt dann brauchen wir mehr verbote
fresken die spd-vorsitzende würde auch
noch ein wochenendfahrverbot dran hängen
ja also ist ja alles schon mal drüber
diskutiert worden von paar jahrzehnten
aber deswegen ich finde darüber reden
muss man aber ich wollte noch kurz zu
ihnen sagen ich glaube nicht dass das
preissignal beim autofahren gerade da
ist und ich glaube auch dass es deswegen
eher mehr gebote als als förderung
braucht weil der tank rabatt macht ja
genau das gegenteil also ich war zwei
wochen in berlin bin da kein auto
gefahren und vater irgendwie hier an der
tankstelle wieder vorbei und guck auf
einmal hoch ist ja wieder deutlich
günstiger geworden klar sind auch die
ölpreise wieder ein bisschen wochen
tolle rat gegeben digital krabat genau
also
tank rabatt ich finde wenn man intern
krawatten macht dann kann man auch ein
tempolimit machen was also weil das eine
beeinflusst ja genauso viele dinge wie
das andere auch tun würde und wir reden
solange schon über das tempolimit und ja
es würde was bringen aber man soll es
doch endlich dann auch mal einführen
viele andere länder haben ist oder man
sollte wirklich mal über andere dinge
dann wirklich richtig diskutieren weil
dieses klein-klein finde ich da ist
langsam muss schluss sein danke dass sie
uns in den sozialen netzwerken bei
presseclub und tagesschau wieder folgen
danke für ihre rückmeldungen und ich
mache jetzt einen cut und greife mal
mark wickel auf der fragt uns nämlich
gibt es eigentlich einen energiewende
fahrplan der bundesregierung
die antwort darauf lautet die alte
regierung hatte keinen richtigen deshalb
hat das bundesverfassungsgericht ist zur
auflage gemacht dass
bundesregierungen regelmäßig
kontrollieren wie viel co2 eingespart
wird das ergebnis für das laufende jahr
war zu wenig weniger als geplant und
versprochen und das ist der grund warum
eigentlich am vergangenen mittwoch die
bundesregierung ein großes konzept
vorstellen wollte das hat sie nicht
geschafft stattdessen sie haben schon
gesagt herr fabricius ist das eine thema
bauen mit vergebens
dargestellt worden das andere thema
kaffee mit herrn wissing und beide sind
ja dinge über verkehren da gerade schon
gesprochen sind ja dinge die sehr viel
mit unserem alltag zu tun haben also
schauen wir auf das thema gebäude und
hören wir kurz der bundesbauminister
hinzu welche gedanken sie da verfolgt
ein punkt das ist auch etwas was ganz
ganz wichtig ist für mich die frage dass
wir über wohnflächen konsum einer
diskussion führen in dieser gesellschaft
also die frage beantworten nicht nur was
hat mein essverhalten mit dem klima zu
tun oder meinen verkehrsverhalten
sondern auch die frage verstehen dass
das individuell wohnen etwas mit dem
klima zu tun hat weil wir natürlich
sämtliche effizienzgewinne der letzten
jahre aufreißen dadurch dass die
wohnfläche pro person immer mehr steigt
der favorit sie haben gesagt da waren
ganz böse sachen die frau gallwitz
vorgestellt hat der appell dass wir auf
wenigen quadratmetern wohnen gehört dazu
ich muss doch eine kleine sache dazu
sagen sagte ich hatte nicht ganz recht
damit wenn sie sagt der quadratmeter
verbraucht pro kopf steigt die ganze
zeit eigentlich stagniert er im
bundesweiten durchschnitt in den städten
und ballungszentren geht er sogar zurück
weil sprichwörtlich der markt dort eng
ist vorüber der flächenverbrauch zunimmt
ist in der peripherie und in ländlichen
regionen da haben wir das
einfamilienhaus ja als flächen fresser
sag ich jetzt mal so auch neue
baugebiete die ausgewiesen werden oder
heizen wir alle zu großer häuser und
wohnungen also nicht alle aber jetzt ja
das ist das ist eine gute frage also im
tendenziell in diesen in diesen regionen
wahrscheinlich schon nur das kann man
natürlich nicht verbieten und das wird
jetzt auch politisch immer extra
wohlstand stadt boten in etwas in
hamburg haben sie schon verboten auf
einer fläche frei stehende
einfamilienhäuser zu bauen da werden nur
noch ein verbot das ist dann muss eben
das wollte ich sagen das ist ganz
wichtig von den begrifflichkeiten her es
geht nicht darum dass jemand
einfamilienhäuser verbieten will oder
auch abschaffen und frau gehört auch
niemanden aus einem haus rausnehmen in
eine wohnung in der stadt aalen
verpflanzen das nicht in die
bebauungspläne werden bleiben sein aber
wenn ich in städtischen und die ganze
diskussion gegen vor anderthalb jahren
los mit dem bezirksbürgermeister
hamburg-nord der gesagt hat ich habe
hier eine dichte stadt ich hatten
mietwohnungsmarkt problem und ich muss
mietwohnungen bauen und hat für sich
entschieden oben in langenhorn da war
noch ein paar baugebiete wenn ich da
jetzt einfamilienhäuser hin setzte dann
löse ich damit nicht dass
mietwohnungsmarkt problem gibt wir
brauchen halt mietwohnung unter denen
die bäder in den ballungszentren
brauchen wir sinnvoll verdichtete
organisch wachsende stadtteile und
quartiere wenn ich überall
einfamilienhäuser an den rand bowden
verbaue ich mir sozusagen das städtische
wachstum das ist das so wohin frau
gallwitz will und sie möchte anreize
schaffen auch in ländlichen regionen
dann erst mal zu gucken bevor ich neue
baugebiete am rand irgendwo aus weil sie
das ich gucke was habe ich denn in der
stadt noch übrig wo kann man gebäude
umbauen und besser und effizienter
nutzen das ist total klimatechnisch sehr
relevant genau was im übrigen ja nicht
nur wegen des klimas wichtig ist dann
haben wir noch ein anderes großes
problem da schauen wir im moment nicht
hin es gibt diese sogenannte
biodiversitäts krise also die tatsache
dass wir immer mehr arten zerstören auch
in deutschland ich glaube 50 hektar
werden pro
helfen sie mir pro jahr pro jahr
einsparen
dass der faktor dahinter steht ist dass
wir einfach dieses land zu bauen und oft
die besten böden und die gegenden wo wir
eben einfach wiesen für insekten lassen
mussten und das tun wir durch die art
und weise wie wir bauen das ist absolut
richtig und wir haben einen wahnsinnigen
konflikt natürlich wir haben einerseits
die notwendigkeit oder die entwicklung
dass immer mehr menschen in die städte
hinein wollen das könnte beendet werden
durch die hohen preise dass wir dann
wieder raus müssen vielleicht auch
leider familien und auf der anderen
seite haben aber auch die situation dass
wir eigentlich städte klimatisch ver
ländlichen müssen wir sind ja hier in
mitteleuropa eine alternde gesellschaft
man ist immer empfindsamer gegen diese
hohen temperaturen wir haben jetzt den
nächsten tage die hitze sie haben es
gerade gesagt herr schönborn das ist
jetzt eine ganz lange hitzewelle aber
wahrscheinlich 35 bis 40 grad da könnten
wir ankommen am dienstag das ist sehr
heiß und eigentlich brauchen wir eine
verlässliche und wir brauchen grün und
blau in den städten also wir brauchen
platz für wasser für pflanzen um
verdunstungskälte zu erzeugen und von
daher ist für mich der gesamten
baubereich und die gesamte städteplanung
ein wirklich zentraler bereich also das
heißt da können wir wirkliche
veränderung es ist letztendlich der
elefant john chain huber hat das mal so
ausgedrückt der damals das pik gegründet
hat es der elefant unter den emittenten
die gravur und allerdings richtung die
neuen nachverdichtung um jeden preis wie
sie sagen bevor wir am stadtrand neue
baugebiete ausweisen müssen wir
unbedingt in den stadtgebieten jeden
frankfurter benutzen und es ist halt
sehr viele dogmen ja also es gibt
irgendwie bestimmte denkweisen und also
dogmatisch denkweisen in den parteien
und das muss alles wir haben ja markovic
am mittwoch von frau gallwitz auch noch
mehr konkretes gehört also häuser und
wohnungen sollen anders beheizt werden
mehr mit strom über die wärmepumpe
weniger mit gas das dämmen soll weiter
vorangebracht werden wir sind ja so ein
bisschen beim blick darauf ob die ampel
uns als gesellschaft voran dringend beim
klimaschutz was ist da ihre einschätzung
nach den vorstellungen ich glaube also
wenn wir aus bauministerium schauen
haben die kollegen ja auch schon gesagt
da kann man schon definitiv punkte sehen
und auch ein planen auch wenn der auch
finde ich noch mutiger hätte sein können
also da hätte man auch noch weiter gehen
können aber beim verkehr finde ich das
absolut mangelhaft in der ausführung was
da vorgestellt wurde und die ampel hatte
grundsätzliches problem darüber haben
wir ja auch schon mal kurz das
angerissen dass man sich da total
zerstritten hat also wir sollten
eigentlich dieses sofortprogramm tut die
komplette bekommen sie haben selber
gesagt und dann bekommen wir zwei
halbjahre programme von daher das finde
ich nicht zielführend also da
fehlt einfach noch einige sind vor allem
der große umfassende plan sie haben
gesagt gibt es einen plan für die
energiewende insgesamt in hätte es ja
eigentlich längst geben sollen er hätte
jetzt vorgestellt werden müssen muss er
in zwei mögliche hindernisse bei dem ich
nun mal das ganz konkrete beispiel also
ab 2024 so die idee sollen neubauten
nicht mehr klassisch mit gas geheizt
werden zwei konkrete hindernisse sind
das erste wir wissen nicht ob es kommt
ist ein vorschlag von frau gallwitz ist
kein gesetz der bundesregierung
zweitens wir haben vor zwei wochen
glaube ich darüber gesprochen dass es
praktisch keine handwerker gibt die das
ganze umsetzen können was ist denn das
größere risiko nicht also ich glaube das
zweite ist das größte risiko weil soweit
ich das verstanden ist eigentlich schon
konsens dass diese 65 prozent
neuer ware in neu verbauten heizungen ab
2024 dass das kommen soll das ist dann
quasi einen de facto verbot vom neuer
anbau der gasheizung und oder gas und
ölheizungen und deswegen würde ich sagen
das zweite das problem der
fachkräftemangel das ist schon viel eher
der fall also wir haben jetzt gerade bei
den erneuerbaren einen riesigen boom die
leute wollen solar die wollen
wärmepumpen und müssen teilweise bis zu
einem jahr mittlerweile auf diese
gerätschaften warten aber wegen
lieferketten problemen und b dann auch
wegen handwerker mangel aber ich glaube
das lässt sich lösen weil es gibt ganz
viele unternehmen die mir spiegeln also
ich bin ja für diesen bereich auch beim
kanzler zuständig und die spiegelmere
die fachkräfte finden wir also ganz
junge unternehmen begehen instagram auf
tik tok die verben sich die selber an
die werden sich die auch im ausland die
sagen wir haben gar kein problem aber
natürlich gibt es das problem
übergeordnet weil nicht jeder
mittelständler kann das und auch hier
ist die politik gefragt mit programmen
entgegenzuwirken fachkräfte aus dem
ausland zu holen noch ein satz wir
schaffen es ja irgendwie auch für jetzt
für den flughafen chaos leute aus dem
ausland ranzukommen das muss ja da auch
bei diesem thema dann aber unbedingt
möglich sein ok also aber interessant
also die wirtschaft ist sagen sie
zuversichtlich dieses problems die
jungen unternehmen sind zuversichtlich
weil sie wissen wie sie die jungen leute
ansprechen müssen aber andere wenn keine
nachfrage noch von david scholz bei
twitter zu diesem thema würde es nicht
fragt er am schnellsten gehen wenn man
auf effiziente geräte setzt also
austausch alter elektrogeräte
belohnen so wie das bei der
abwrackprämie beim auto der fall war ich
glaube man muss ganz viele dinge
gleichzeitig tun das ist ja dieses
problem mit dieser energiewende es gibt
nicht die eine wunderbare maßnahme dass
man irgendwas anschaltet und irgendwas
anderes abschaltet sondern es gibt ganz
viele punkte und deswegen ist hab ich
muss man bei dieser diesem umgehen
dieser regierung mit dem thema auch noch
mal den finger in die wunde legen es ist
im moment robert habeck der vier macht
frau gallwitz hat da würde ich ihn zu
stimmen auch ein paar ganz interessante
ansatzpunkte und das ist alles
kompliziert aber wir haben eben nicht
eine bundesregierung die diesen plan die
sich zusammensetzt und sagt wir haben
fachkräftemangel warum sagt er weil
jetzt nicht hat nicht eine idee wie man
die fachkräfteausbildung an wirkt also
das ist ein gesamtkonzept fehlt und ich
glaube da muss man dann auch den
schuldigen noch mal beim namen denn das
ist im moment die fdp die das ganz
massiv verhindert weil sie
offensichtlich die analyse hat dass ihr
mehr klimaschutz bei ihren wählern nicht
viel bringt und das ist im moment die
partei die bei ganz vielen blockiert
statt zu sagen wir haben eine
marktwirtschaftliche zugang zu dem thema
wir machen dass man zu unserem und wir
können das besser als die grünen anfang
ich muss ich muss ich einfach mal gerade
ein sozusagen aus meteorologischer
perspektive und die das macht mir immer
ganz fertig also wir agieren freund von
mir hat mal gesagt auf ameisen kniehöhe
mit diesen ganzen dingen weil er einfach
gesagt hat wir sind noch weit hinter dem
zurück also wir wir müssten theoretisch
ich komme oft vor als sitze ich vor
einer
umwelt rettungs filme ich sitze da vor
und alle machen ganz leichte dinge und
ich bin ganz verblüfft warum eigentlich
niemand kapiert wo wir wirklich stehen
also diese 1,5 grad die werden wir 20 26
hochwahrscheinlich hat die welt
meteorologie organisation gesagt
überschreiten wir erleben 34 grad am
nördlich des polarkreises wir erleben
waldbrände ohne ende wir erleben jetzt
eine kurze hitzewelle ja wir haben wir
haben unglaubliche entwicklungen dieser
murata in den alpen das muss man sich
überlegen ein ein eis sturz weil es dort
auf 3300 meter 13 grad grad gab wir
werden das in zukunft öfter erleben wir
werden das verschwinden der gletscher
möglicherweise erleben in den alpen was
dazu führt dass unsere flusspegel sich
ganz anders verhalten also ich glaube
wir haben noch nicht wirklich
registriert und begriffen dass die welt
in die wir hinein rutschen mit dem was
wir da auslösen eine ganz andere sein
wird als wir heute erleben und dem muss
man sich jetzt stellen und da stimme ich
ihnen dann vollkommen zu wir brauchen
einen klaren plan und es ist glaube ich
immer schwierig wenn drei parteien sich
irgendwie zusammen tun von denen man
vorher wusste das ja eigentlich nicht
organisch zwingend zusammen gehören und
das erleben wir jetzt aber wie mans
since lahti eine klare analyse es liege
an der fdp bei der satz und gibt es bei
fälliges nicken am tisch oder andere an
schätzungen über das zum produkt
bezogen
bisschen auf dieses fachkräfte thema
eventuell also das sehe ich jetzt zum
beispiel nicht also ich sehe nicht dass
die fdp verhindert nicht nur bei den
fachkräften sondern der eigenen bei
klimafragen liebe kennt er gut generell
kann man das vielleicht sagen aber den
klimawandel zu bekämpfen das ist ja muss
ja auf vielen ebenen stattfinden und gut
man muss natürlich auch sagen da muss
man der fdp kann man vorhalten würde ich
auch vorhalten die das thema
schuldenbremse ja natürlich müssen wir
jetzt wie sie passt in eine attraktive
misna geld in die hand gar nicht in
erstaunlichen schritt gemacht also es
gab ja einen hohen milliardenbetrag der
eigentlich für corona folgen als
schuldenaufnahme vorgesehen war
sozusagen schon mal sagen wir aus der
schuldenbremse grundgesetz rausgenommen
war und da hat herr lindner zu
allgemeinen erstaunen gesagt eigentlich
müsste das zurückgeführt werden aber wir
stellen das für klima zu brauchen jetzt
mehr zusätzliche investition genau
werden gerade dieses haus positionen
meine frage italiener wirklich so auf
der bremse wenn er auf der anderen seite
mal eben so ich glaub 60 milliarden die
eigentlichen anderen zweck hatten zur
verfügung stellen wie hals gefallen muss
ich ganz offen sagen
die analyse jetzt da bin ich schon quasi
gegen meiner grundsätze habe ich gegen
meine grundsätze verstoßen also kann ich
jetzt dann beim klima nicht so viel
liefern wie das möglicherweise nötig
wäre also ich glaube das ist einfach
eine wahltaktische überlegungen statt
eine wirkliche inhaltliche und wenn man
schon schuld verteilt ich würde sagen
das große problem ist tatsächlich die
fdp aber wir haben eben im moment auch
ein bundeskanzler der kein klima zahl im
kanzleramt hat wie das der amerikanische
präsident beispielsweise hat oder andere
also scholz hat das thema immer noch
nicht zusagen gemacht und ich glaube das
ist das zweite problem war bin ich muss
einmal also ich sagen jetzt kein
fdp-vertreter am tisch der ist auch
übernehme ich jetzt mal die sind
wahrlich keine parteienvertreter die
besitzt die position wenn sie sagen das
große problem ist die fdp die fdp ist ja
von menschen gewählt worden die gerade
nach der pandemie den wunsch hatten dass
der staat weniger vorschreibt dass
weniger ins leben eingegriffen wird also
es insofern nicht gesellschaftlich
geboten dass eine partei mit redet die
einen teil der wählerinnen und wähler
vertritt unbedingt ich kann mir nur
vorstellen dass auch fdp wähler und da
bin ich bei den bürgern von den staat
eine gewisse schutzfunktion erwarten
wenn wir in diese welt kommen die wir
eben skizziert bekommen haben dann sind
es ja auch fdp wähler und wählerinnen
die darunter leiden werden und ich
glaube auch die haben recht darauf dass
der staat sich schützt vor dem thema
krisen bobby darin ich würde daher eine
zahl 48 prozent der fdp-wähler sind auch
für diesen geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung
geschichte also ich will jetzt auch
nicht nur diese fdp beschuldigen die
gibt es gerade den vorschlag auf meinen
tempolimit nicht nur für verbrenner
einführen können könnten elektroautos
weiter war
aber verwirrt sie hatten vorhin so in
den raum gestellt das mit dem gebäude
wurden überzeugt sie zumindest in teilen
aber
das thema verkehr und dann möchte ich
jetzt darauf zurückkommen herr wissing
ist unser verkehrsminister
was er gesagt hat am mittwoch ist etwas
wo wir doch alle zustimmen können die
ladeinfrastruktur für elektroautos
verbessern ja wir sind aber auch dann
wieder wieder bei der fdp die hier
sachen vorgestellt hat die sind usus und
die sind auch nicht neu lade
infrastruktur ausbauen radwege ausbauen
die pnv ausbauen
es gab ganz und elektroautos weiter
fördern es gab viele streitpunkte die
überhaupt keine eingang darin gefunden
haben und anders als bei frau gallwitz
fehlt bei herrn wissing wirklich jeglic
ist detail also wie werden radwege
ausgebaut wie soll der öpnv attraktiver
gemacht werden was ist mit der
weiterführung eines klima tickets egal
in welcher höhe das wird völlig
ausgelassen also ich finde hier gibt es
sehr sehr viel zu kritisieren weil das
fand ich völlig planlos auch einfach nur
auf elektroautos zu setzen ist laut
vieler und immer mehr experten ohnehin
keine lösung einfach die autos
auszutauschen sondern wir brauchen ja
ein ganz ganz neues verkehrskonzept ein
ganz neues mobilitäts denken und das
finde ich fehlt hier völlig ja also ich
habe jetzt eine querverbindung nochmals
zu dem thema gebäude ja weil es ja auch
darum gehen gibt es eine partei die
gebremst aus meiner sicht ist
gebäudebereich die partei die grüne ist
eine sind einfach auf dem falschen vater
weil sie die ganze zeit jetzt möglichst
viel verbraucher neue stromverbraucher
in die haushalte reinbringen will die
wärmepumpe wird jetzt als es vorgezogen
dass das jetzt die heizung
der wahl sondern es werden wir werden ab
20 24 kein richtiges gasheizung verbot
haben da ist jetzt ein papier gerade
herausgekommen man kann dass er mal
machen sie den vor der st zum nächsten
thema also zum thema verkehr zu jetzt
aber wichtig ja ich habe viele leute
wehren sich jetzt wieder fragen muss ich
jetzt kann ich jetzt endlich kann die
gastgeber und das stimmt nicht ich werde
auch ab 2024 das steht in diesem papier
drin eine gasheizung einbauen in
kombination mit einer wärmepumpe wenn
die 30 prozent ist es erlaubt dieses
hybrid gerät muss ein pufferspeicher
haben ist irre aufwendig aber ich würde
sagen 80 prozent der haushalte werden
wahrscheinlich dieses gerät werden dann
kommt aber neue stromverbraucher ans
netz und da sind wir wieder beim strom
wir haben die e mobilität und dann wären
wir wenn wir in den nächsten jahren mehr
wärmepumpe haben wäre wärmepumpe haben
werden bis 2030 sonst sechs millionen
sein dann werden wir 40 terawattstunden
mehr strom benötigen und das wird in den
nächsten jahren wieder kohlestrom sein
und elektromobilität da stimme ich zu
das ist jetzt würde ich jetzt sagen wir
als beobachter der dinge einwänden der
sprechen über die frage ob die ampel
einen plan hat sie hat verabschiedet
dass zwei prozent der fläche in den
bundesländern künftig für windkraft zur
verfügung gestellt werden aha beck will
genehmigungs hindernisse beseitigen er
bild im naturschutz der windkraft
verhindert weniger gewicht geben
auf den ersten blick erscheint mir dass
eine antwort auf die frage wo kommt der
strom für die autos wo kommt der strom
für die wärmepumpen her hat leider ist
das ein wichtiger teil eines
zukunftskonzepts ja wir müssen vor allen
dingen da auch schneller werden wir
müssen uns getrauen also entweder wollen
wir erneuerbare energie oder nicht wir
können nicht sagen wir wollen keine
windräder wir wollen kein atomstrom mehr
wollen keine kohle wir wollen überhaupt
nur den strom aus der steckdose das ist
physikalisch ganz schwierig das heißt
wir müssen eben so eine idee verfolgen
das ist jahrelang nicht passiert oder
viel zu wenig passiert selbst in bayern
überlegt man jetzt 10h also windrad
zehnmal so hoch wie abstand
abstand zimmer sowie windrad
zu kippen und wer nicht ganz freiwillig
nein nicht ganz freiwillig aber das ist
unter dem druck der momentanen
bedingungen ich hoffe ja immer noch dass
dieser druck da jetzt entstanden ist und
dann
also es ist eine so schlimme situation
auf dieser welt aber wenn wir daraus
lernen dass wir unter diesem druck den
putin jetzt aufgebaut hat endlich die
erneuerbaren wirklich so ausbauen wie
wir das vor langer zeit ja immer wieder
erzählt haben dann könnten wir hier
natürlich einen gewinn erzielen und dann
muss man auch das windrad ertragen klar
energie sparen bedeutet weniger
windräder das heißt darüber nachzudenken
und zweitens ich sag mal den leuten aus
dem psychologischen satz weil dann die
leute das mit dem also jeder muss für
sich einschätzen ob ihr oder ihm das
windrad passt oder nicht ob das die
landschaft verschandelt das kann ich
nicht beurteilen für andere menschen
aber ich kann zum beispiel den leuten
sagen guckt mal auf eur strommasten die
sind auch nicht so wahnsinnig schön der
strommast war nur immer schon da an den
hat man sich gewöhnt windrad kommt noch
das heißt wir hätten energie erstellen
müssen wir brauchen den ausbau der
erneuerbaren wir brauchen den massiv
schnell und entschlossen wir haben auch
möglichkeiten zum beispiel was die
wasserstoff herstellung als nächste
komponente angeht da diskutiert man so
viel über den norden afrikas das finde
ich auch gut dass man es macht das ist
eine wichtige region aber der süden
europas kommt mir viel zu wenig auch
dafür brauchen wir ja strom ich
versuchen einmal das größere bild zu
malen also wir sind uns alle völlig
unheimlich solar im süden sie haben es
gerade noch mal erwähnt also
energiesparen ist ein thema das wir
eingangs hatten dass eine große rolle
spielt und ansonsten scheint sich ja
alles auf die energieform strom zu
konzentrieren von dem deal auch das ist
klar egal wie viel ersparen künftig
deutlich mehr brauchen werden und jetzt
komme ich nochmal zu meiner frage
windkraft zurückkehrten zeiten in
deutschland da wurden jedes jahr 1000
1500 1700 neue anlagen gebaut jetzt ist
es nur noch ein bruchteil davon frau
pinzler also ist das der durchbruch ist
dieser plan von herrn h weg mehr
windräder zu bauen trägt er ist der
wirksam und ist eher ein beitrag zur
lösung des problems also was er jetzt
haben es das sogenannte oster paket was
jetzt im sommer dann tatsächlich
verabschiedet worden ist jetzt das
sommer paket schon da das wird dann im
herbst verabschiedet das muss auch noch
kommen das reicht immer noch ans
auspacken das oster paket ist da
wirklich mehr windkraft drin ist immer
da ist mehr windkraft drin auf jeden
fall leider ist es immer noch leichter
und schneller ein lng terminal zu bauen
als ein windrad also da geht immer noch
mehr tempo wenn wir vom wind noch die
sonne mit dazu nehmen wir haben immer
noch keiner solardach pflicht auf der
häusern waren bauen wir nicht überall wo
wir bauen jetzt solarflächen
mittlerweile überall die sonne scheint
auf jedes dorf aber wir haben sie haben
nicht als pflicht man könnte es als
pflicht machen wo es sinnvoll ist also
auch da das ist ein großer schritt und
sie haben tatsächlich recht wir haben so
denke wir hatten sondern auch künstler
dann kapriziös dann folgt eine kurve die
gingen so nach oben und dann kam der
sogenannte altmaier bauch also runter
altmaier ist es wahnsinnig eingebrochen
mit dem windrad das heißt wir sind dann
jetzt daten müssten eigentlich dahin und
jetzt geht es langsam wieder hoch und
das ist dann auch wieder diese
fachkräfte geschichte die frage bekommen
die ressourcen her da ist ein guter
schritt in die richtige richtung ist das
der richtige plan und wird er wirksam
sein ist es der beitrag zur lösung den
wir uns alle wünschen also so viel
windkraft wie möglich und so viel
solarpaneele auf den dächern wo es
sinnvoll ist wie möglich das ist auf
jeden fall der richtige richtung ob das
jetzt und wie man den planern umsetzt
also an pflichten da habe ich große
zweifel in nordrhein westfalen die neue
schwarz grüne regierung plant ja so eine
pflicht da sind aber auch schon wieder
ausnahmen formuliert in diesem plan der
noch nicht gesehen ist da wo ein baum
davor steht wo schatten ist wohl jemand
das finanziell sich nicht leisten kann
da soll es nicht geben es wird ist viel
zu kompliziert in der umsetzung ich bin
der ansicht der staats wollte einfach
sinnvoll fördern aber nicht unbedingt
den rohstoff solarpanel die kommen aus
china sind billig geworden weil wir die
alle dorthin verloren haben man müsste
die speicherlösung fördern wenn ich
warne und das ist nämlich der nächste
schritt ich warne vor der illusion dass
wir einfach mit sonne und wind strom das
ganze jahr über die ganze energie bedarf
in deutschland decken können das immer
so ein bisschen so ein ponyhof denken ja
da drehen sich die räder und erscheint
denn die sonne und dann haben wir den
strom jetzt überall verteilt denn
massives leitungsausbau problem das wird
noch 20 jahre also wir müssen
deutschland für dieses bild eigentlich
auch so eine kupferplatte draufstellen
das hat mir mein ingenieur erklärte er
der sich damit beschäftigt dann könnten
wir irgendwo im norden würde ein windrad
laufen im süden kommt der strom an wir
brauchen zehntausende tonnen kupfer für
diese vision und selbst wenn es so weit
sein sollte wir werden nur einen
bruchteil wir werden vielleicht 20 25
prozent des strombedarfs ist leichter
aber wir wollen den ganzen welt 6 auch
noch elektrifizieren allein an erdgas
über 4 100 terawattstunden größere die
netze machen
ist jetzt noch drin sein wenn ich in der
schweizer energie akzeptieren müssen
beide haben absolut recht ich glaube
trotzdem es ist viel was habe ich da
gemacht hat für die windkraft und das
problem ist nur wir werden das erst in
ein paar jahren sehen und dann wird
schon wieder knapp weil der wind ausbau
geht leider nicht nach oben der ging
nach unten ist es weniger als letztes
jahr genehmigt und was genehmigt wird in
diesem jahr wird erst in zwei jahren
frühestens gebaut also da kommen wir
auch eine ganz klare zeitnot rein und
auch da muss noch viel passieren dass
hoffentlich kommt dann im sommer paket
ich versuche mich kurz zu fassen 100
prozent erneuerbare nur aus solar und
wind funktioniert natürlich nicht möchte
noch mal kurz nur die bioenergie
reinwerfen
sich wort bei oster sommer dann
vielleicht herbst paket
kommt mir schon der gedanke dass wir ja
eine bilanz über einen recht kurzen
zeitraum zu die regierung hat im
dezember oder so richtig erst im januar
die arbeit aufgenommen insofern habe ich
die zwischenbilanz verstanden energie
importieren solar und wind sind wichtig
sind es nicht alleine die schlussfrage
mit der bitte um eine kurze antwort
stammt von jan spangenberg auf twitter
und er fragt gibt es einen weg indem man
zumindest den großteil der ziel
geschafft ohne dass die bevölkerung
leiden muss
zweiteilige antwort man braucht das
kurzfristige im moment da sind wir zu
langsam aber es gibt zum beispiel für
mich immer einen punkt energieberater
kostenlosen jede schau schicken
gemeinsam mit den leuten sofort ran
gehen was können wir machen klar haben
wir das techniker problem gegebenenfalls
wir haben lange ideen wovon einige die
die regierung macht aus meiner sicht
wirklich richtig ist das möchte ich auch
mal hier betonen dass nicht achten sie
ist sondern es gibt gute ansätze über
die wir gesprochen haben und danke eine
sache jetzt einsatz befindlichen berlin
gibt es viele schaffen ohne zulagen ich
glaube den gibt es nicht es wird hart
werden im herbst die frage ist wie
verteilen wir die lasten richtig und das
ist bleiben dadurch die nächst
verwendung da müssten sie zu laden
würde ich zustimmen gibt es nicht aber
mittelfristig möglich
stimme ich auch so also es wird es wird
schwierig es wird erstmal sehr teuer
vorübergehend aber der staat muss
bessere anreize haben sich alle nicht
getraut ihn einst zu sagen ein bisschen
aus flucht also nein ohne
mittelfristig ne bedanke mich herzlich
für das gar nicht zusammenpassen schön
dass wir dabei waren hier in der ard
jetzt das europamagazin und wenn sie uns
weiter verfolgen wollen presseclub
nachgefragt dann im radio und im
fernsehen bei phoenix und lassen sie es
gut gehen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück presseclub
nachgefragt im fernsehen bei phoenix im
radio bei wdr 5 jetzt sind sie dran und
wir beginnen in koblenz am zusammenfluss
von mosel und rhein bei vorgang dazu sie
uns große nach koblenz
meine frage ist kurz und klipp und klar
hand aufs herz sind irgendwelche
numerisch zu benennenden klimaziele zum
beispiel dass man wenigstens zwei grad
erreicht die materie überhaupt mit
marktwirtschaft und demokratie zu machen
ich halte das für absolut ausgeschlossen
das ist das was zum beispiel hat recht
wir brauchen ein anderes geschäftsmodell
und das meint nicht nur tempolimits oder
so sondern dass man dann in der frage
des verkehrs wird individuell praktisch
kein auto mehr gefahren und ähneln sich
das würden wir müssen ja mit der welt
teilen
und das bedeutet wir müssen zwei drittel
unseres verbraucht einschränken und was
ist der kern ihrer frage
der bkk die basis schaffen wir
irgendwelche klimaziele auch nur die
geringsten überhaupt mit demokratie und
marktwirtschaft stelle das in frage
okay da wir demokratie und
marktwirtschaft haben und auch nicht in
aussicht steht dass sich das verändert
heißt die frage schaffen wir
irgendwelche klimaziele ja also schaffen
wir irgendwelche ziele ja ja auf jeden
fall und marktwirtschaftliche prinzipien
bieten auch genügend anreize um von
fossilen brennstoffen wechsel kommen
genau das sehen wir ja gerade gaspreis
verdoppelt sich und verzicht fangen alle
an zu reagieren natürlich die politik
nicht so strikt wie sie müsste aber erst
am marktwirtschaft reicht dafür aus wir
haben forschung und entwicklung
unternehmen bekommen einen anreiz
alternative energiesysteme und
speichersysteme zu entwickeln also
sozusagen die marktwirtschaft ist egal
eigentlich der beste die beste plattform
dafür um dastehe reagieren zu können die
politik muss aber die richtigen
rahmenbedingungen setzen ist natürlich
klar nathusius ich verstehe die frage
gut denn bisher das kann man ja sagen
haben wir immer nur ziele gesetzt wir
eingehalten werden ja eigentlich glauben
wenn man jetzt dass alles getan wird um
jetzt die verhalten wieder in gang zu
bringen ihr punkt ist angekommen bedanke
mich rusal koblenz und wir springen nach
erfurt zu
werner schädlich willkommen im
presseclub ja hallo herr schöner brunnen
willkommen beim ja auch und herzlichen
gut in die runde sie haben das wort ihre
anmerkung oder frage ja sehr gerne wir
erleben momentan kräuter aufgrund der
aktuellen energieproblematik
die frage wer sollte nun die
verbleibende energie die übergabe kommen
soll ist die großindustrie bekommen so
dass der verbraucher bekommen meine
frage konkret an die runde der bürger
hat es so hin schon angedeutet
vielleicht einmal mehr auf die
wasserstofftechnologie zu setzen und
wenn ich ihren mast wäre oder ich sag
jetzt einfach mal ein konsortium von
großunternehmen oder menschen die
einfach das geld dazu hätten würde ich
mich in richtung nordafrika begeben
würde dort ein solventer machen oder
entsprechende projekte angehen mit
tausenden von quadratkilometern
photovoltaik was technisch möglich ist
davon würden sehr schnell und sehr
kostengünstig wasserstoff produziert und
diese wasserstoff würde mit schiffen zu
unserem lng terminals kommen und schon
wäre das problem gelöst weil die
großindustrie die ja auch schon
angedeutet hat dass sie sehr gerne quasi
stahlindustrie und so weiter mit
wasserstoff agieren wollen in zukunft
die werden dann satt und der verbraucher
wäre entlasten ein gutes teil geschafft
danke für dieses bild das sie gemalt
haben genau und ich habe verstanden ihre
frage ist ob das eine kluge investition
wäre freiwillig
ja ich denke das ist eine kluge
investition beziehungsweise sehr viele
unternehmen und länder scheinen das auch
zu denken denn was schädlich gerade
beschrieben hat passiert tatsächlich
seit ein paar monaten ein anderthalb
jahren würde ich sagen kommt das so
richtig ins rollen
anfang oder vielleicht und da wird
investiert das ist in marokko im
mittleren osten in afrika
aber auch in saudi arabien wird gerade
sehr viel investiert um den umschwung zu
schaffen weil viele länder darin
tatsächlich einen wirtschaftlichen
nutzen für sich selber sehen zum
exporteur für grünen wasserstoff zu
werden ich glaube dass man immer wieder
erklären was ist das wasserstoff
letztlichen stromspeicher ist ne also
nur vom strom also es ist ein in anderer
form zu transportieren ja genau ja
natürlich und es braucht aber auch eben
wasserstoff im molekül form für viele
prozesse in der industrie das heißt wir
werden er wird auch strom hergestellt
definitiv aber
genau wird auch in reinform dann am ende
auch gebraucht werden wir gehen nach
warendorf zu brigitte küster das ist
wenn ich es richtig weiß bei christa in
der nähe von hamburg
nein wenn halo ja sie sind in der
sendung und ich lasse mich gerne
verbessern
hamburg
rockstar entschuldigung aus kölner sicht
ist lüneburg auch in der nähe von
hamburg gekommen und sie sind
meine frage richtig liegt mehr an herrn
plöger und zwar ganz kurz beetle anteil
an der klimaerwärmung
hat der rohstoffabbau zum beispiel am
ländern wir wollen da ja suppe rohstoffe
raus und da hätte ich gerne mal eine
prozentuale
hey
prozentuale zahl ja also sagen wir mal
man muss hier gucken also der
rohstoffabbau ist das eine und welche
rohstoffe über welche funktionen dann am
ende co2 oder treibhausgase emittieren
müsste man jetzt nach rechnen also wir
deswegen kann ich ihnen keine
prozentzahl so direkt sagen aber wir
können durch unser wirtschaften was wir
tun und unsere emission feststellen dass
die klimaänderung derzeit viel schneller
abläuft als die natur das macht so dass
viele wissenschaftler sagen dass der
menschliche anteil den wir im moment bei
den veränderungen erleben bei ungefähr
also einige sagen 100 prozent oder nahe
dran es gibt immer noch natürlichen
einfluss aber ganz erheblich ist und da
ist natürlich die ausbeutung wir nutzen
jedes jahr die nachwachsenden ressourcen
von 1,8 erden und eine deswegen ist das
dauerhaft ja auch so nicht machbar und
deswegen müssen wir uns ja über eine
transformation gedanken machen zu müssen
so dass auch getraut eine kreis cradle
to cradle im grunde brauchen wir eine
kreislaufwirtschaft von der wiege zur
wiege und müssen ganz viele dinge
verändern und das wäre immer noch mal
ein gedanke von mir dass wir uns
wirklich auch getrauen dass jeder ich
bin ja freiwilligkeit ist ja was gutes
aber jeder muss für sich auch mal
wirklich darüber nachdenken wo sind denn
die eigenen spielräume ich bin ja immer
noch für ein pflichtjahr wo jedes jede
frau und jeder mann ein jahr seines 80
jahre langen lebens abgibt in
anführungszeichen um über soziale fragen
und umweltfragen wirklich und zwar
professionell
angeleitet zu werden um einen anderen
blick zu bekommen ich halte das zentral
weil wir sind am ende ein gewinn für die
gesellschaft manchmal muss man sich bei
dem wort pflicht auch getraut frank
küster das war jetzt doch ein weiterer
vorschlag gruß nachbarn dorf wir haben
viele in der leitung ich gehe weiter
danke dass sie dabei sind und benjamin
miano in wildberg hallo herr miano wo
finden wir wildberg auf der landkarte zu
finden hier vom stuttgart willkommen
guten morgen
meine frage oder erst mal ab also die
journalisten scheinen sich relativ einig
zu sein ich bin diametral gegen ein
tempolimit ist vielleicht noch kurz vor
ort als statement meine frage die
diskussion in ihrer runde war sehr also
auch auf nationale auf nationaler ebene
geführt und ich frage mich tatsächlich
mit den ganzen einschränkungen und den
ganzen einbußen und die twitter frage
vom abschluss ihrer sendung hat uns ja
auch ein bisschen deutlich gemacht
zeigt für mich im prinzip die diese
isolation in der betrachtung also wenn
wir deutschland den co2 ausstoß auf null
fahren würden würde das der welt so
passt gar nicht bringen das würde den
klimawandel vielleicht ein paar wochen
nach hinter nach hinten verschieben und
mit dem ganzen eine einschränkung frage
ich mich wie kommen wir dann dazu dass
andere länder uns folgen also china oder
indien oder anderen die eigentlich noch
deutschland erreichen wollen wo die co2
vermeidungskosten viel geringer sind als
in deutschland
wir müssen doch wohlstand
technologieentwicklungen zusammen für
mit klima wandelt damit uns andere
länder folgen weil wenn wir uns nur
einschränken denn kramten sind wir
vielleicht der moralischen
verpflichtungen gerecht geworden unser
co2 einzusparen aber es bringt uns am
ende nicht wenn wir wenn die welt nicht
machen ja nur danke künstler es gibt
immer dieses argument mit den zahlen wir
sind ja nur zwei prozent für zwei
prozent der co2 emissionen weltweit
verantwortlich wir sind aber nur ein
prozent der weltbevölkerung
also wir haben dann selbst wenn wir nur
ein prozent der co2 emissionen
verantwortlich wären dann dann kommt mir
aber klage von der milano geht er in die
andere richtung gegeben mach jetzt einen
unterschied dann geht ich habe die frage
so verstanden also wie kann man zum
beispiel china oder andere also was
können wir dazu beitragen dass man auch
in anderen ländern gute modelle für den
klimaschutz hat und wir haben also ein
beispiel dazu dadurch beigetragen haben
ja hallo habe ich es richtig verstanden
die antwort jetzt eben gegen schon
wieder in die richtung ja wir haben zwei
prozent und es ist aber das geht ja nur
auf moralische verpflichtungen aber mir
geht es ja um das ziel mir geht es ja um
das ziel am ende den klimawandel ein
stückweit abzuwenden und da riss im
boden haben sie mich natürlich richtig
verstand mir geht es darum ein
erfolgreiches modell zu implementieren
damit die großen emittenten das sehen
und außerdem als beispiel folgen er gibt
nicht um moralische debatten wir haben
fünf prozent und jetzt müssen wir aber
wenn wir am ende ab und unterstützt bis
antalya lassen sich mich nur einmal über
china reden der pro kopf ausstoß an co2
in china ist deutlich geringer als in
deutschland das heißt eigentlich könnten
wir von china lernen und nicht jeder von
uns und dann muss man glaube ich auch
noch dazu sagen und internationale
politik ist wie so ein system der
kommunizierenden röhren wenn wir das
hier hinbekommen dann gibt es eine menge
länder die das dann kopieren werden weil
die samba wenn die deutschen mit ihrem
industrieland das schaffen dann können
wir das auch schaffen im moment passiert
aber das gegenteil im moment reißt der
bundeskanzler in den senegal und sagt
fördert doch bitte wieder gas das heißt
unser beispiel könnte dann schule machen
also das ist noch ich habe eigentlich
immer das beste versprechen dass wir
hier nur immer eine antwort auf einem
input haben
ich glaube sie haben das deutlich
gemacht danke dass sie dabei sind groß
nach wildberg und
dann gehen wir zu manfred hütter nach
rosbach guten tag herr gitter
guten tag ich
habe mal eine frage an die runde
und zwar geht es ja bei klima in der
regel immer um erneuerbare energien die
müssen gestärkt werden die müssen mal
immer mehr immer mehr die neuen
erneuerbaren energien erzeugen doch aber
ausschließlich strom aus sonne oder wind
es ist ausschließlich strom was bringt
das mir denn beim heizen wenn ich mit
gas heizt die erneuerbaren energien
können wir doch da überhaupt nicht
helfen vielleicht ab 2024 oder 25 bis
dahin ist doch aber noch eine menge zeit
also warum immer erneuerbare energien
die helfen durch gar nicht auf allen
gebieten
sie sind der haus experte der wohn
expertin das ist jetzt natürlich genau
der plan dass die heiztechnik in
deutschen häusern auf strom umgestellt
werden soll als energiequelle die
wärmepumpe ist eben wie gesagt das
mittel der wahl das hatten wir eben kurz
schon die läuft mit strom die wird die
die verdichtet restwärme aus der umwelt
und er werden denn damit das
heizungswasser im haus und läuft mit
strom das ist also das ist eigentlich
der große generalplan das problem ist
halt wir haben viel zu wenig strom dafür
also der erneuerbaren energien werden
dafür überhaupt nicht ausreichen die
reichte nicht mehr um den strombedarf
den wir jetzt haben zu decken jetzt von
der heißen die idee von mutter ist dass
er als mieter oder eigentümer irgendwann
die gasheizung abschafft und mit strom
heizen ganz genau wobei
das wird in den vielen häusern die
mehrzahl der deutschen wohnimmobilien
ist nicht für die reine strom betriebene
wärmepumpe geeignet der wird denn der
stromverbrauch im winter so hochgehen
wenn es wirklich kalt ist dass wir die
netze also da müssen wir wissen dass
tausende user nicht ereignet das ist der
dank dann wird er jetzt das jetzt kann
das ganz neue papier was aus dem
bauministerium kommt da wird er
wahrscheinlich ein hybrid gerät einbauen
das ist eine wärmepumpe kombiniert mit
einer gasheizung und die gasheizung
springt dann ein wenn die wärmepumpe mit
die strombetriebene werden sozusagen
überlastet ist also so oder so irgendwie
wird der strom anteil am werbemarkt
zunehmend das ist das ziel aber ich
glaube nicht dass wir vollständig auf
strom umsteigen werden der user ich
danke ihnen sie merken es wird aber auch
kompliziert an der stelle ich würde gern
noch einen hörer reinnehmen deshalb sage
ich jetzt danke bin unhöflich und sagt
auf wiedersehen und gehen nochmal nach
augsburg klaus frank hat uns angerufen
er frank-peter hier impuls ihre frage
ganz meine frage wo ist die
vorreiterrolle der öffentlichen hand
weist bei der umsetzung sei es bei der
tatsächlichen erleichterung von vorhaben
und beschleunigung von vorhaben daran
gekoppelt warum wird die wird das thema
lnt beschleunigt aber der bau von den
südlichen trassen oder anderen
stromtrassen oder netzausbau weil sie
keiner weise beschleunigt mir fehlt hier
ein bisschen die technologie frei
grundsätzliche marschrichtung und meine
frage ging hier eigentlich ein vom
künstler bzw
ganz wie z denn mir fehlt das große
ganze thema und die vorreiterrolle
wenn wir allein becher ansehen becher
für das photovoltaik oder auch thermo
solarthermie sind innenstädten zu
hunderten vorhanden in der öffentlichen
hand wären alle als kleine kraftwerke
mit sicherheit im großen ganzen
einsetzbar künstler sind angesprochen
das hat nicht gerade schon geantwortet
ja ich kann die andere noch ganz kurz
machen da das ja eher ein statement war
deine frage kann ich ihnen einfach nur
zustimmen sie haben recht es fehlt ja
danke für den hinweis
warum fehlt das ich glaube weil sich da
sind dann wieder bei dem was für ein
blöder vorhin gesagt weil sich immer
noch nicht in dieser bundesregierung die
das gefühl durchgesetzt hat wir müssen
jetzt das ist echt richtig richtig ernst
und wir müssen das jetzt müssen alle ran
und das muss dann runter dekliniert
werden bis zu der einzelnen kommune da
sind ein paar also würde ich mal wieder
von kommunen die da auch vorreiterrolle
haben es gibt welche und zwar die sind
sehr intensiv daran die haben sehr gute
kontakte zur bevölkerung da gibt es die
energieberater die unterwegs sind diese
beispiele müssen wir vielleicht auch
medial viel öffnet um deutlich zu machen
sind passiert was was wir aber insgesamt
haben ist eine viel zu langsame
bürokratie bis unsere ganzen
genehmigungsverfahren bis das alles mal
durch ist dann wollen wir am grünen
tisch alles zu 100 prozent besprechen
daher schaffen wir durch zerreden fast
nichts ich hätte gern 70% im visier
würde 50 schaffen und deshalb hatte die
ampel tempo versprochen und fortschritt
und ich verspreche wir bleiben dran
beobachten dass weiter ja in einen
schönen sonntag schön dass sie dabei
sind und lassen sie es gut gehen
[Musik]